we're here we're queer [__]
oh [__] it's a beautiful [__] day to
be alive [__] you thought I
forgot about you I never forget about
you [__] savages understand me Monday
Thursday Friday Sunday don't [__]
matter I'm like Michael Corleone his
wife and the Godfather Italian one she
couldn't tell the days of the week
Monday Sunday Thursday Wednesday
[__] that [__] and don't need to be no
four [__] 20s for amateurs we're from
the Church of what's happening now we
show up whatever the [__] we wanted you
dare enter this house it's time for a
little afternoon smoky smoky with uncle
Joey
what's happened you bad [__] is
a beautiful day to be alive grab your
balls sniff your fingers and let these
[__] know why God gave you
another day the sling dick uncle Joey
here on point I worked out this morning
I wrote I did a bunch of [__] errands
and now it's time to [__] take a
little smoke break with my family cuz as
usual I'm with you you're with me and
these [__] savages want to be with us
but listen I didn't invite you here to
[__] chitchat let's smoke a couple
bulbs and see the devil I got this
[__] dead over here and I got this
death over here left that on two legs
that's what this weed is called you're
tearing me apart I can't take it no more
so you know what this weed is call a
chuck norris kick to the head yebin you
have to have that a Chuck Norris kick to
the [__] head don't worry about 4:20
will live on 228 [__] that was
worried about 228 what are we gonna do
today who gives a [__] about 420 321 3 1
it's how you're gonna swing nicked boy
ome more how you gonna make it [__]
put the pieces together today I play in
two minutes smoke another Bowl and the
[__] Confucius weed will come to me
tremendous I hear my ears ringing that's
one if that's a good sign when you eat
Chinese people yelling and screaming I
got Apocalypse Now anyway how a BAM I'm
sorry I couldn't make it this week in
Huntsville I got that TV show so I'll be
[__] busy doing that but you know what
i'ma do a little work and I would uncle
Joey at the ice house March 10th at 7:30
on a Saturday night to try out my
material for [__] night
I'm working on you know I'm working on
things you know uncle Joey I always got
something to put together and then the
21st of March they just added a [__]
show I had a [__] levity live in
Nyack New York this is for the Bronx
Brooklyn Queens all you mother [__]
savages the Gambino's are gonna be there
the Luke Cage these are gonna be there
the Cubans are gonna be there
Renee and Kostya on with the Puerto
Ricans will be there forget about it
you're gonna have a good time that's
what I'm trying to say you might smell
[__] things but who gives a [__]
nothing wrong with a little smoky smoky
eye no Wednesday afternoon yet I'm
saying you got to show up I'm walking
sometimes look at this [__] this is
death on two legs is what Hadley [__]
did you see Lee yesterday and a bunch of
[__] spots this weed is guaranteed to
give you spots you know Sam maybe one or
two of them on the forehead people you
think it's a [__] split by the
something anyway this finds out the
birds are chirpin and I don't give a
[__] jack we're going for broke well
because this is a podcast tonight I
don't know what time I don't know a lot
of things but there'll be one tonight
you understand me anyway
what the [__] you can't walk on one leg
let's do another little tutu roots and
then I'll send you back to your [__]
days and you forget about it once you
get back you'll be brand new tip-top
Magoo the other two changes you don't
give a [__] jack I'm only here for one
more hour a [__] to do and people to
[__] see that you're twenty two
push-ups
you got your [__] goals you got a
smoke you gotta work the eyeball you
follow me and don't forget Isis is still
out there so keep the eyes open there's
people with guns gyms and but that means
you gotta show up with a gun you know
when they'll stop shooting people when
these people start shooting them back
it's a sad but true anyway where's
Metallica when my daughter goes to
school miss and their school with two
Puerto Ricans one with a bazooka moment
ago a grenade one of those little
[__] kids come in they're [__]
dummy I'm saying a bazooka missile right
to the [__] eyeball no more [__]
[__] shooting kids that said it's over
anyway you know I love you [__]
and they ain't getting political but I
have a child now and I have a think that
way you could buy a gun anyway you go to
[__] any handball court in America you
see two black dudes you like some do you
don't know what he is it could be
Filipino it could be Chinese and black
whatever they got a gun for sale could
be a 22 well give me an AR 15 years
gotta go over an ass you want to play a
handball and they'll know the [__]
code that's as easy it is to get it I
got a gun in two [__] minutes just go
to a [__] handball court that's where
you get the best guns in town those guns
don't miss they've killed eight people
you follow me anyway who's talking about
killing joy we just want to have a good
[__] day here that's it you're
absolutely right
oh I love it when I start hearing sirens
and [__] like that
anyway like I said next to [__]
Armenians are in that house what are you
kidding me
listen I feel safe around the are most
they might [__] people
the lady who cuts my hair Armenian the
guy who drives me to the [__] Airport
I mean Ian where I buy my weed Armenian
who puts the patches on my DS the
Armenians the Armenians got my [__]
back who do I get flowers from the
Armenians who's my chiropractor the
Armenians are you [__] nuts I'm down
with the [__] that Armenians I walk into
Glendale
I put a cigarette out they light it they
call me [__] Monsieur and they're not
even French you know I'm Sam
who the [__] better than Armenians
nobody I shout out to my man Armenian
[__] birdy over there and Glendale
holding it down you need some you
[__] get all the birdy IDs passports
[__] travel packages whatever you
need a toaster he don't give a [__]
sometimes he shows up with bread that's
my dog anyway I smoked one more right or
wrong I'm gonna bother you for mid
afternoon I'm gonna show up with a gun
with no [__] bullets who the [__] am
I don't forget March 21st we had another
show up there and [__] at NIACC and this
for my brothers and Queens Long Island
it's too far for you people I don't want
you get DUI the way back is for my
[__] soldiers in the Bronx Brooklyn
Staten Island and northern New Jersey
follow me I'll see you at [__]
diagonal Wednesday night ready to go
bring the [__] wreath for the bazooka
bring everything last time I got a show
in math and I got hit there with a
bottle I said type of place that is you
follow me I need my strong [__]
in the house as usual security of
billion Renee and Carla shows up with
ten Puerto Ricans on a [__]
motorcycle and you're [__] you ready
to go right no forget the mango today's
through I'm India North Bergen fire
department I'm giving you a shout-out
not Bergen in the [__] house
is where I got this wit from the town of
North Bergen these [__] they
steel with three hands and they don't
give a [__] jack anyway
I'm up on the road
Obie another boy they didn't get my
method to I saw it what got DC tails
wrong column over on the iron anyway
that's my little spit moment there so
little space we jump up and down at home
norm representing always Mexicans Cubans
are Argentinians I love you
[__] you little [__]
[__] you jump fences we swim we
do everything anyway what a mile in the
house Nicaragua in that house Colombia
I've been with you mother [__] since
1978 you know same Colombia's got no
problems with me and I got no problems
with them the Gemini lounge that's the
Voodoo Lounge that's the [__] Roy
DeMeo hangout come by sometime will stab
you throw you in the shower and then
we'd some meatballs anyway I love you
[__] along my heart I'll see you
tonight don't forget it's Wednesday
[__] Gentiles are falling apart rough
day at work savages like this is just
getting started you know I'm saying
they're all tired I need to Starbucks
double my coaching I'll get the [__] out
a Gentile [__] would you string some
[__] soup lemon juice from the
[__] faucet
anyway Church tonight at 8 o'clock from
[__] Ice House March 10th 7:30
at Nyack New York March 21st and I'll be
there to 20th for the signing of the
corporation with my man TJ English and
undisclosed location I'll let you guys
know in a few days and I'm saying anyway
I love you [__] stay tough don't
let nobody [__] with you today and if
they give you a problem dumb open Joey
sent you you follow me anyway stay black
god bless you hug your mother and most
importantly make somebody's day that's
the most important thing you want to
have a good day make some
these day and I said you see a little
gay guy let him touch your dick give a
guy a dollar helping a kid with a
[__] kite take the cat down from a
tree hug somebody don't grab their ass
then that puts you in a different
category you know I'm saying anyway I
love you [__] stay black see you
tonight